state justified thank you
edwin black talks about an agreement
made between hitler's government and a
group of zionist leaders in 1933.
the agreement called for the transfer of
55 000 jews and 100 million dollars to
palestine in exchange for calling off a
planned economic boycott of nazi germany
by jewish organizations
barnes and noble booksellers in
rockville maryland host the hour-long
event
so we're here with edwin black and uh
most people know you for some of the
best sellers some of the books that
mitchell's just referred to ibm the
holocaust war against the weak internal
combustion banking on baghdad all of
these books bestsellers were written
however in the 21st century
you have i understand somewhere around
69 different editions
published in about 14 languages in 61
countries the question that we're
focusing on today was actually your
first book called the transfer agreement
the dramatic story of the pact between
the third reich and jewish palestine
this book was published in 1984 so it's
been 25 years ago and at the time that
it came out i remember there was a
tremendous amount of media attention and
also it was a very controversial book it
was uh one that there was a tremendous
amount of discussion about it and so
that's really what brings us here today
um can you let's go first to that issue
what was it about the publication of
this book and the the thesis that you
were putting forth what was it that
garnered so much attention and so much
controversy the story of the transfer
agreement
is the story of the pact between the
zionists
and the nazis that was
launched
in the first weeks of the third reich in
1933.
it began in the spring of 1933 and was
consummated
in uh
august of 1933.
most people don't know that when hitler
came to power the jews actually fought
back and they fought back hard and they
fought back immediately
hitler came to power on january 30th
1933
the first concentration camp was uh
actually on uh opened up of a series of
them between march 8th and march 10th of
1933 the anti-jewish laws followed
shortly thereafter and by march 27th of
1933 the jewish war veterans right
had actually
started
a series of international protests and
mart and marches and on march 27 of 1933
one million protesters jammed madison
square garden and there were a boycott
and protest boycott and protest
movements all over the globe led by the
jews but certainly involving um the
interfaith community the labor unions
anyone who wanted to profit at germany's
expense and to protest the nazi regime
so we're talking this is about 10 12
years before the outset of of onset of
of world war ii uh
world war ii began at 6 a.m on uh
september 30th 1939. right so we're
talking uh hitler came to power in 33
the nuremberg laws in 35. uh crystal
knocked in 1938 the war in 1939
and most of the genocidal uh period the
so-called final solution i guess would
have begun in the summer of 1941 the
fall of nine of nine of 1941 and then
commencing at full speed in 1943 four
and five
so
what the zionists did
was they realized that protest was
fruitless let's take a moment let's be
sure we define the zionists those are
the people who what were they doing the
zionists
i believe that most people don't know
what the word zionism means
well at the end of the uh 19th century
there are a number of nationalistic
movements across europe there was uh the
concept of armenian nationalism there
was east european nationalism the
ottoman empire was falling apart there
was a wide group of people who were
seeking to self to to self-govern one of
these many groups
was the jewish people was the jewish
peop jewish people and zionism is
nothing more than jewish nationalism
the jewish nationalists
the jewish nationalists the zionists
seeking to legally
uh
uh organize themselves into a state
under international law which was done
through the league of nations
um sought to uh move the jews who were
persecuted especially in europe into
jewish palestine most people today
think of palestinians as arabs
but the entire world
in 1933 he thought the word palestinian
meant jewish nationalism
zionist the jewish agency for palestine
the palestine post jewish palestine
that's why the subtitle of the book is
jewish palestine be sure because that
was the body of the jews
in what what became the state of israel
it was called jewish palestine and the
term for the jews
internationally recognized in ordinary
parlance and officially with palestinian
palestinians so they used to refer to
jesus pal as palestinians so these
zionists were the advocates then for a
jewish homeland pick up our story in
terms of they saw
the end before anyone saw the end
and they said the only thing that we can
do
to save a remnant because they saw it
coming they knew the history of the jews
the recent history and the distant
history they saw it coming
and they made a deal with the reich
to transfer out
the jews
of nazi germany and other parts of
europe
into palestine
now how you going to do that
that's going to be impossible because
who's running palestine
palestine is being run by the british
it is being run under the so-called
mandate system which means the league of
nations man
mandated palestine which was turkish
territory before that uh to be a jewish
homeland
but there were rules in place
and the rules and this is important the
rules were that jews could not enter
palestine right
without five thousand dollars in cash or
a thousand
uh british pounds
and this was called the so-called
capitalist immigration certificate
now how does a jew
leave nazi germany
where there are currency restrictions
where no one can bring a reich mark out
of germany how does that jew get into
palestine as a so-called official
refugee
the answer is the germans concocted the
idea and the zionists concocted it with
them
that
german goods
would be sold
and as german goods were sold
money would be produced a jew in germany
in this complex arrangement would take
his personal household possessions and
assets and put them in a special bank
and that bank was called pal troy
then a second bank was set up
called the anglo-palestine bank and that
bank was in palestine
the money would be put into the german
bank
the nazi goods would be sold by the
zionist organization
across the middle east and especially in
palestine
when the goods were sold they generated
revenue when which went into the
anglo-palestine bank the anglo-palestine
bank then provided the money for the
jews to bypass the currency restriction
that the british have imposed and they
would come in in the process
the nazis could restore their economy
the nazis could break the boycott
because you could not transfer a jew
by selling the goods at the same time
boycott the goods
the infrastructure
of jewish palestine
was built up
pipes
steel
breweries
homes
cars buses
all of these these things german made
and i wondered when i first went to
israel why are there so many
mercedes-benz running everybody asked
that we all asked that question right
and that's where i really start well is
that what got you interested in the time
in this topic
no what actually got me interested in
that we'll actually get to that in a
little bit it was a it was done
let's stay with what you're talking
about
so i wrote this book and explained how
it happened and in the process
25 years ago i was the first one
to talk about the economic consequences
of the holocaust
at that time
people said why are you talking assets
they were still trying to comprehend the
enormity uh the scope of the bloodshed
how many people died how many people
were gassed how many trains were
were there people were not talking about
money now today that dominates the
conversation as assets i want my
property back i want my insurance back i
want all these things back but in those
days it was all almost blasphemous it
was a few decades ahead of its time to
discuss the money consequences but i
real i realized
that the scope of the bloodshed was in
many ways linked
to the economic impact of the holocaust
in addition i was the first one to use
the word nazi and zionist in the same
sentence
now it is today everywhere
especially by the enemies of the jewish
state but defected
defective at that at that time it was
completely unexpected
and so that's why the book was extremely
controversial that's why there uh the
media jumped on it i went on a giant
tour and even though i did my best to
convey the information as best as i
could it was quite shocking and so we
have
people hiring psychologists to go on
television and analyze me
did people assume you were saying there
was a sense of cooperation between the
nazis and the zionists and that was part
of what then was so disturbing well they
were trying to say that um
i was blaming the jews right
for their very own fate instead of
seeing uh this whole elaborate scheme
and and in terms of in terms of a rescue
got it in fact i had a problem with my
own parents who were survivors
from the train to treblinka and forest
fighters who thought that i was perhaps
revealing something that should not be
revealed
as i said i do remember uh the storm of
controversy and there were articles
coming out and this and that and uh
uh and yet here we are today and and it
seems as if the jewish community is is
now much more open to to this well
they're open to it because uh
um uh of course i've been established in
the jewish
community my credentials uh of fighting
for jewish causes and for justice and in
in holocaust matters is now well
established uh
back when i wrote this book originally
yeah the american zionist or designer
organization of america
canceled
the publication of their um magazine the
american zionist arm press because they
had a cover story about about this topic
today mort klein of the americans of the
zoa
has read the book and uh endorsed it as
a sensitive
so do you want to share with us then
what took you into this line of research
this was your first book right
uh this was my first book and prior to
that i'd been um a local investigative
reporter i had done some international
uh undercover investigations uh um i was
involved in an undercover operation on a
the last slave state in the middle of
the indian ocean
uh and when i did and when i did that
um
my agent uh uh an agent approached me
from william morris
and said we want you to write a book for
us what are the top five books you'd
like to write and i said well the one
book i gave them all sorts of ideas
right i said the one book that is uh too
hot to handle is the transfer agreement
what really motivated me to get be
involved in this was the skokie march
tell us about that well i think i was
fundamentally naive i fundamentally i
was in such a cloistered typical jewish
neighborhood environment
that i couldn't understand how
jews could operate against their uh
perceived self-interest and during the
skokie march
i interviewed the jewish attorney for
the nazis right
i said how can you do this at that time
i was schooled by a professor byron
sherwin of spurtus college who said
there are many things we can't
understand and he told me there was
something called the transfer agreement
i didn't believe it and uh finally i
assembled a team of 20 or 30
historians and
holocaust survivors and children of
holocaust survivors there was no second
generation movement
we went
into five or six countries
accumulated all the information some of
it was not even in the archive it was
under people's desks it was being
protected i went into the jewish agency
i went into the leo beck institute
uh and i found the information i
assembled it and i produced the book so
you're taking us to to the process of
putting it together um it's important to
stop for a moment because the the
elaborate way in which the scheme
was structured and then to try and
uncover it and just what you've referred
to right now
at a time pre-internet uh access uh to
to that kind of information uh must have
been quite extraordinary so uh maybe you
could share for our listeners a little
something about um the uh nature of that
the research that went into it and
putting together a team to pull all this
information together
there was no internet there were no
computers
the manuscript was typed
and every time i changed the footnote
they had to re-type the entire
manuscript it was retyped 30 times wow
uh by the way on an ibm's electric
uh so i was using the best ibm equipment
even back then
um i did this in the um in the in the
late 70s in the early 80s
um we've had to assemble everything by
hand
we did everything by uh
carbon paper and by a photocopy there
were very few xerox places in israel was
hard to make a copy but we assembled a
team
and
we had all these meetings and we found
the information most people didn't know
what we were looking for
and at one point i ran into an archivist
who in israel who seemed to know
where all the files were hidden and i
said to him how is it that you know so
much about this he says i was in the i
was in the transfer agreement wow and
the word transfer in here in hebrew is
havera which means transfer
transfer limited havara limited was the
name of the overall company
and you must remember this was
encouraged by the nazis cooperated with
by the nazis and the nazis and the
zionists actually worked together
because they had an intersecting
interest
the nazis wanted the jews out of palace
out of germany
zionists wanted them into palestine
the nazis wanted to seize german assets
german jewish assets
the zionists wanted to save german
jewish assets and the only way they
could do it was by this transfer
agreement so the nazis were willing to
work with jews on this is that what
you're saying that's right
but
their desire was to to ultimately to
exterminate the jewish people so was
this before they had gone down that path
or it just it was it was serving their
greater interest explain that to us a
little bit
understanding the nazi period for real
is understanding a complex
set of situations
uh it was actually byron sherwin from
spurtus college who schooled me on the
new approach
to understanding both the reality and
the perception of reality and the
perception of reality often
dictates the the real set of facts that
occur on the ground and can and uh and
tumbling down the road
the
nazis saw
working with the j with the zionists as
the best most expedient way to stop the
boycott
and to get the jews
out of germany
where were they going to go they're
going to go to palestine now there's
another train of thought here
the nazis believed in something called
vokish thought
that means ethnic
primacy okay and they believed that the
um uh that the germans
had the vokash primacy in europe and
they thought that the jews needed to go
to palestine quote where they belonged
and so you had
uh the uh uh fantastical idea of um
of goebbels and others publicly
endorsing
jewish immigration to palestine the
nazis actually struck a coin
with a jewish star on one side of the
swastika on
on the other while all the jewish
organizations were shut down the
zionists were allowed to maintain their
operation
and were allowed to grow but you must
understand
when the zionists published their
newspaper
they had nazi sensors in the office
overlooking every line people don't
understand exactly what the nature of
the invasive nazi regime was
it is easy to say they could have fought
back and on many levels people did fight
back but what designers did is they were
the realest the cold hard realists
so so let's talk about within the
context of the jewish community then um
and and and the response because you're
bringing up some important issues here
uh people there's a lot of
misunderstanding um did were jews
passive were they uh resistant um you
alluded a little while ago to the nature
of uh of an anti-nazi boycott um so
if you could just share with us a little
bit about the uh
the backlash and what the jewish
community was trying to do
in response to the early
rise to hitler's early rise to power
okay we need to look at this is two
titanic forces
the boycott
to [ __ ] the reich
and the transfer effort
to save the jews
they seem to be on competing uh uh uh
parallel competing attracts here yes uh
no they are on a collision course that's
one thing conclusion okay they're on a
collision course because they cannot
co-exist
the boycott movement did what had to be
done
the jews
condemned the nazis they had million-man
marches
um
there was a a boycott in every city uh
it was led by the american jewish
congress
by stephen wise a famous name in jewish
history there were rogue boy there were
rogue boycotts organized boycotts and
these were saying to all americans as
well as jews especially just americans
it was in chuckles it was in
czechoslovakia it was in england it was
in france saying don't find good schools
german goods and services was there
opposition to that by the way boycott or
was there yes there was opposition
within the american jewish community
it's very easy for people who look at
the american jewish community today and
beli and falsely believe it's monolithic
but you and i both know
uh that the jewish community back in the
30s was anything but monolithic it's a
very complex story but the jewish
community was comprised
the jewish leadership in in this country
was mainly run
by what were known as german jews
hoffuden which is the courtly jews they
didn't want to rock the boat so much not
only did they not rock the boat they had
led all the vigorous boycotts and
protests against the czar
against france
against uh
damascus
they were the ones who fought back
whenever jews were persecuted and
whether or not the regime in question
the czar would take retaliation or
revenge upon the inhabitants was never
an issue they always had to stand up for
jewish rights okay and they successfully
defended jewish rights
all over the planet
in this case the jews who would be
retaliated against were not some russian
guy called sasha
this would now be
their uncle heinrich their cousin their
daughter
it would hit her so they were afraid
there would be a backlash against jews
in germany and some were counseling wait
a minute we should back off on this yes
and who am i talking about let's get
names american jewish committee they
were anti-zionist
in those days in those days not now of
course
and bene britt anti-zionist and
also german jewish in its uh major
composition
and these guys
wanted to work quietly behind the scenes
petitioning government officials they
wanted nothing to do with any vigorous
protest against nazi germany
contrast that with the other jewish
organization not the
committees
and the elite but the democratic jewish
people and that was the uh eastern jews
the so-called american jewish congress
it's really like labor and management
sure it was really the the pop the
population against the elite and the
population said we're going to protest
this we're going to not and what did
they have to pro to protest what was the
weapon that the average jew had to fight
hitler
the money in their pocket that was it
and not not to use it for nazi goods and
not to use it for nazi goods not at the
same time what are we talking about the
height of the depression
so if you're going to boycott uh
german pharmaceuticals in china and film
and
other uh goods and services for
czechoslovakian french american lots of
people are going to join that labor
unions the czechoslovakians catholics
who were out who were outraged by what
was being done in germany protestants
this was interracial this was
non-sectarian true it was led by the
jews but they were very careful to be
all inclusive and never call this a
jewish boy a jewish let's also keep in
mind there's also the nativist movement
in the american the 1930s that's right
the jewish community was nowhere near as
well organized or as as willing to uh
take positions as they are today
advocating on behalf of their fellow
jews in part because of everything
you've mentioned here in some way did
this boycott feed into jewish notion
german nazi notions about jewish power
that was the power of the boycott
you never measure a boycott
in nickels and dimes
or fit or fenigs in marks you measure
boycott in ergs of fear okay
how afraid are you of the boycott
and were they were the germans the nazis
believed in jewish boycotts
the nazis believed in in an
international jewish conspiracy which
controlled money and markets
adolf hitler personally lionized his
hero
who was his hero
henry ford
and what brought henry ford down a
jewish boycott
run by the american jewish committee and
bene britt and the congress against uh
the ford motor company and this was
vividly in the minds of the nazis so the
nazis believed in the boycott almost as
much as the boycotters believed in the
in the boy
in the boycott if anyone comes to you
with statistics they don't know what
they're talking about because it's fear
it's economic fear that ruled the
economy and the relationship so how does
this transfer agreement play into
that backdrop of the boycott without the
boycott the nazis would have seen no
necessity to work with the transfer
agreement
without the so in that way the boycott
succeeded to kind of like succumb and go
around it so to speak that's right by by
subverting the boy the uh the boycott
they could do the transfer agreement the
trans agreement succeeded
um uh because it did bring the jews
out of palace uh out of germany into
palestine created a jewish state and had
that not occurred no one has a doubt
what would have been the fate of those
jews were there other areas of
cooperation by the way uh between the
nazis and and palestine at that time
yes there were there were undercurrents
economic cooperation yes none of this is
simple this was complex and that's why i
spent five years putting it all to
together jewish palestine was half
agrarian if not mostly agrarian at that
time in 1930s
the jews did not own much of the land uh
which they did buy with transfer
agreement money they did not have a big
infrastructure but they had farms
and what was the biggest product i'm
going to guess oranges was it oranges
was debate was the big product of jewish
palestine it was the economic
wherewithal who was the number one
customer
for oranges from jewish palestine
nazi germany
so
now jewish palestine
which uh was of course abruptly
surprised on january 30th with the uh
takeover by adolf hitler jewish
palestine is now looking at their number
one customer
really not saver which is the which is
the third reich and if those oranges are
not purchased there can be no economic
vitality for the um for jewish palestine
and there was the constant threat
by uh the third reich we won't buy
jewish
or oranges from palestine will buy
fascist oranges from spain
valencia's so this is one of the
important unknown undercurrents it's
easy to see this in black and white my
challenge the challenge of history
is to see the complex grays that
established this very murky picture well
let's go to some of those complex things
because obviously just even in terms of
what you touched upon so far this was
not a simple kind of a thing it sounds
like there's a lot of moving and
shifting and and and maneuvering going
on uh in terms of international
merchandise purchasing sales so can you
share with us then uh what were the uh
dynamics
of the transfer agreement what was the
you know uh essence of it okay it it
starts out with uh a jew in in
germany taking his money and putting it
into a blocked account
now reich marks were hard to identify
they had dozens of different types of
reichsmarks and reichsmark values but
generally speaking across all these uh
fictitious and real marx systems it was
about five thousand reich reich about
five thousand reich marks would equal
the amount due the jew would put his
money into a blocked account a spare
canto and that account would be
fundamentally a trustee account
and that would be run by this bank in
germany
then they would sell goods they would
sell pipes they would sell taxis they
would sell it in palestine they would
sell it in lebanon they would sell it in
turkey they had all different types of
commercial distribution for german goods
when the money
was
made available the money was deposited
in a second bank
the name of that bank was the
anglo-palestine bank
the anglo-palestine bank renamed itself
after the state of israel was
established and the name is now bank
lumi
same bank
anglo-palestine bank would take that
money
credit through an international
clearinghouse the uh the
german
trust fund
the german trust fund would issue
uh the
foreign currency
of a thousand british pounds a
capitalist certificate would be given to
the german jew
and that german jew would then come
across
and in many times he came across with
replicas of his own home he came across
with carpets he came across with um
with a building materials he came across
with cars he came across with musical
instruments and suddenly there was a
massive german jewish and
infrastructural and economic infusion
into jewish palestine so let me ask you
it's complex okay leaving aside the
complexity let me just ask a simple
question then
was this then uh
a situation whereby the jewish community
and somehow was contributing to the nazi
efforts and helping to finance what it
is that they wanted to be able to do
yeah
and that and and that must have been
also one of the uh causes for such an
explosive reaction to your book right
yeah
it's a deal with the devil not not with
the angels it's a deal with the people
who want to kill you so basically
every time
they rescued a jew
they paid into the nazi economy
and
it's worse than that
i mean there were many dynamics that i
never even wrote about but the jews were
compelled
the jews were compelled to rescue jews
in this fashion it was a terrible a
choice to have to make it was a terrible
choice that was thrust upon the jews but
you do not
upon the zionists but you do not blame
the uh the hostage
with the gun at their forehead did the
zionists consult with anybody on this or
they just said you know what we've got
to do this and this is what we're going
to what we need to do do they talk with
the american jewish committee or i mean
i assume i know the answer they just you
know went on their own is that right
they didn't care about the american
jewish committee right
in fact zionism was controlled out of
london until this time
and by the time uh
the trans agreement came to the fore
the access point
for a
zionist um authority had transferred to
jerusalem and so the people on the
ground in jerusalem were making
decisions and
they weren't just taking anyone on a
first come first serve basis they were
actually concomitantly building the
state of israel and so consequently they
they took the people who had a chance of
surviving
okay in jewish palestine not just anyone
when we've when we've used this term the
zionist that's the zionist leaders the
jewish nationalists any particular
leaders in in uh that that were uh that
we know of who were uh um involved in
advocating for this yes the entire
jewish agency we're talking david
ben-gurion we're talking
we are talking about another
gray not black and white fabric
does just as i said the american jewish
community was divided between
these two different blocks in the
zionist community also the zionist
community was also
monolithic
there was what was called at that time
the labor party the
the the mumbai party sure you're talking
about people like ben gurion you're
talking about a guy by the name of khaim
ar lazarov
everybody who's been to israel has been
down the street called our lazarus
absolutely right and al-azerov was the
chief engineer
of this agreement
and he was murdered for it
on the beach in tel aviv
at the location
where the hilton now stands
in tel aviv right there there was no
hilton there at that time and he was
killed presumably
by
the followers of the dissident zionist
faction and that dissident zionist
faction was led by a group
associated with menachem bagan but
really associated with uh with tinder
the revisionist and they called
themselves revisionists and the term
revisionists at that time meant we have
a new idea
for uh zionism and these were the
fighting
zionists these were the zionists who who
said we want to fight hitler we don't
want to have a deal with him and
consequently as the jewish community was
torn apart on the uh subsuming and
subverting the uh the boycott design his
community was fighting they had riots
they had um uh contentious votes they
did they they were tearing their hearts
out saying how can we cut a deal with
these nazis because
right now it's common to say
uh the nazis weren't thinking of
extermination
i've gone into the record
my first use of the word
my first common use of the word
extermination in nazi literature goes
back to 1933 and that's because that was
the word they used in in world war one
to exterminate the arm of the armenians
was extermination so consequently it was
a word of parlance of the day and design
is completely expected
everything that happened because they
had a complete grasp
on jewish history
uh on the worthlessness of jewish life
at at the hands of murderers they had
seen many many jews die
in eastern europe and in other parts of
the world so i want to fast forward now
we're talking about the controversy that
occurred then we'll talk about the some
of the controversy about the book um
on a personal level
uh exposing this dealing with this
writing about this uh obviously must
have been uh uh a lot of uh well i don't
know what to say uh whether it was ad
hominems attacks or whatever
what was it like when the book first
came out
for you in that context well this was my
first book i was only um you know i was
in my 20s when i started it uh came out
in 1984.
um i i had been the editor of uh of a a
city magazine but i've never been in
exposed on the international stage
the book was published
world worldwide
and
people were shocked surprised confused
there was a town hall meeting
set up in chicago to discuss this
and it was supposed to be in some little
jcc
social room
and by one o'clock so many people had
made reservation they moved it to uh to
a large synagogue
and then they moved it to
a football stadium
and i had 1100 people
waiting
to hear me uh talk about this and um
it was rough there were people who uh uh
they said that muammar gaddafi was
financing me
i had picket lines said my parents were
from kuwait of course the polish
survivors
they
hired psychologists to psychoanalyze me
why am i doing this book but ultimately
the test of time the historical veracity
the truth of the book were you were you
surprised or did you anticipate that it
may have that kind of reaction by the
way
i was
i anticipated because that was my
reaction okay
i hated the project
but you like the book
well i wrote the book rewrite the book
the book had to be written and i and i
wrote it and i wrote it so it was a
story you thought had to be told yeah i
was on a a quest
so so with trial by fire from my first
book it prepared me well for ibm and the
holocaust did so were you surprised as
you were doing your research with
where you got in other words or or when
you started it did you think it would uh
reveal what you ultimately learned about
the the the whole setup the entire book
covers
the minute by minute developments
in three countries
accounting for time zone shifts
in jewish palestine
germany
and the united states we have diplomatic
uh
uh messages going back and forth and it
only covers the first eight months
of
1933. it's very very intense
it accomplished what i wanted to do
which is to understand
what had happened
and um
so you went into wanting to understand
but my question did were you surprised
by the conclusion or you kind of as you
started to get into it
i never wanted to find the conclusion
that i had okay okay it was pretty it
was it was pretty wide
and it's kind of like that with a lot of
my books
i never believe how far it's going to go
and i take it to the end of the factual
line
i i remember you're telling me about the
ibm book and saying you just stood at
the holocaust museum staring at the
ibm
machine there and wondering the computer
why is that there so i know that you
just process it and think about it what
were uh tell us about some what would be
uh
when the first to come out the the worst
moment your your most gratifying moment
as well just
well the worst moment
the worst moment what was the worst
moment
the worst moment was probably
when
i had a guy
there were people
attending my uh one of my lectures
and he was an undertaker
and uh he said to my parents we want to
bury your son's book
wow
the best moment
was when i won the carl sandburg award
from the best book of the year
and i uh became a cost celeb in the
jewish media and from there i developed
a syndicated column
in um
in 50 jewish newspapers on the strength
of the transgression the jewish media
actually well i didn't even know there
was a jewish media i didn't know there
were at that time jewish newspapers in
every city and the jewish newspapers
plastered this all over and gave it a
great deal of credence and it gave me
entree
to
pursue my wider mission of exposing
injustice against the jews
uh holocaust factuality and verity and
to do the other things that i've done
so it really launched your career you
went on you became a columnist in jewish
newspapers as well as i believe for the
jerusalem post and elsewhere yes i was
syndicated throughout the world in fact
uh louis farrakhan granted me the first
interview
um
uh um
to uh the first interview for a jewish
journalist
because he had read the transfer
agreement
and um based on that book he actually
made a statement often uh quoted the
jews have a gutter religion uh the jews
made a deal with the
nazis and i think this is what he's
referring to and i know because the
jewish author wrote it
and so there are a lot of um uh
antagonists who use this information
to invalidate the jewish state
and who used this information falsely
to um uh to claim that the holocaust did
not exist
it is just but these same people will
use the bible the biography of golda
meir the biography the autobiography of
ben gurion uh moshe dayan they will use
anything that that that they have and
they are frustrated by the fact that i
have brought out the truth which is that
the jews that design his rescue jews now
there were transfer agreements in other
in other countries there was the
potentiality of rescuing millions of
jews
millions of jews could have been rescued
you have to ask yourself whether or not
the nazis would have been stopped by
people running up and down the street
with placards
or whether it took something more the
zionists were the only realists of the
time and by the way
there was no country
there was no major corporation
there was no major
organization that did not have
vibrant
relations commercial and diplomatic with
the nazis
at that time so let me ask you a
question uh your website lists the many
uh different books you've uh written on
topics you've talked about whether it's
oil addiction whether it's
the holocaust whether
other topics if i'm not mistaken
this is not one that you usually talk
about right
i do about 300 events a year i talk
about ibm the holocaust i talk about oil
addiction
uh nazi nexus
all of these books i don't talk about
the transfer agreement uh it almost
seems to me if i can say this
i don't want to be uh psychoanalyzing
you said before almost like you have a
love-hate relationship with it yeah i do
yeah
um i always tell people read this book
last
i've i've got eight eight eight eight
nine books in fact i told a reviewer
from the miami herald uh if you review
this book you're gonna hate it
it's not a comfortable book to read well
it was a less comfortable book to write
but
the holocaust is not comfortable and the
truth is never comfortable
now in the uh the the back of the book
as well as in the
uh when you signed it and and you did
this for me as well you wrote you asked
the question was it madness or was it
genius yeah
um you want to shed any light on that do
you want to
well
all genius is based on madness
so it was both
well it's it's a brilliant work and an
important one uh what i want to do now
is i want to turn things over to uh
mitchell bard who is going to
share with us some questions that some
other scholars have submitted um and uh
we'll take it from there
well it's hard to know where to start
with uh with this subject but martin
gilbert who as
you know is winston churchill's
biographer
and he's the author of a number of books
on the holocaust and author of a
forthcoming book on muslim rules of 1400
year history he wrote
what do you think would have been the
impact on the israeli ability to absorb
holocaust survivors in the 1940s had the
transfer agreement not occurred in the
1930s the main value of the
transfer agreement is 1.9 1.4 to 1.7 to
1.9 billion dollars the equivalent
dollars in
today's money that was transferred
over was not trinkets it was
fundamentally infrastructure
when uh jews came over
uh during the uh hitler period
and uh on moss and after the fall of the
third reich they called they came over
in huge waves
where were they going to live what water
were that where were they're going to
use
where were the roads going to be um
where were the lands
um had the transfer agreement never
occurred in 1930 in the 1930s there
would not have been the infrastructure
to rapidly
absorb
all of these jews let's remember this
the not the nazi program was continued
as you well know
uh after world war ii um
by the arabs
they expelled approximately a million
jews
from arab lands uh in the years after
the fall of the third reich these people
were not put into refugee camps they
were quick they were quickly quickly
absorbed the name of the immigration
ministry in israel is called the
ministry of absorption and they absorb
these people and so the answer to
martin gilbert is that uh had um uh
israel the state of israel not been
aided with this import important impetus
during the depression years
it would have been i think difficult
to absorb hundreds of thousands of jews
who came on mars during the years to
follow and this was in fact anticipated
i have another question from professor
samuel edelman in chico california who's
the executive director of scholars for
peace in the middle east he asks there
were other transfer agreements across
europe such as one truck in
czechoslovakia romania hungary
why didn't those succeed in transferring
more jews to palestine well
this is true there was a transfer
agreement uh
in italy there was a trans agreement in
czechoslovakia in in romania they each
had their own financing schemes and as
the situation became more dire for the
jews
in europe remember hitler went into
czechoslovakia and he went into austria
and it began to take over europe
the zionists rushed frantically to set
up more transfer agreements to save the
jews because
you must remember this very important
statement and i will quote you a phrase
you know well
that kai and weitzman said the world is
divided into two places
those places where jews cannot live and
those places where jews cannot go
there were
most people think that evian is just
water you buy at the store the avion
conference lives with us in 1938
as what to do with hundreds of thousands
of refugees where the doors were shut
so palestine was the only door open to
the jews they weren't allowed into uh
into most of the nations of the world
so
these transfer agreements
had the possibility
to transfer hundreds of thousands of
more jews romania hungary
most of the hungarian jews were wiped
out
in transports they were organized by
in hungary by the
one of the members of the board of
directors of ibm
edmund wiesenmeier
and imagine if these
uh jews had come by the boatload
literally
into jewish palestine what happened
the war happened
economic stopped
international trade became ill
illegal
and the zionists were not able to
continue
transferring these monies out in an
effective and meaningful fashion and so
the war
caught up with the transfer agreement
before the transfer agreement could
catch up with the genocide
professor byron sherwin of spurtus
college the author of many books on
ethics and most recently the life worth
living
who was also you mentioned the the
scholar who first told you about the
transfer agreement asks
uh you first heard about the agreement
in an interview you did with me in the
1970s i recall that when i told you
about it in very general terms you found
it hard to believe that it actually
happened now after all your research
writing and thinking about it do you
still find it hard to believe that it
happened
i didn't believe it happened in those
days because i wasn't smart enough to
know that it happened i wasn't wise
enough to know
i'd barely been out of chicago
uh the march in question was one in
skokie where where my parents lived it
was just outside
what
if i was presented with this information
now
i would believe it in an instant i would
have never believed that ibm would have
had a 12-year
um
uh pact
a widespread commercial coalition with
the third reich to identify the jews and
even to create the basis of the
auschwitz tattoo i would have never
believed that the rockefeller foundation
would have financed the program that
sent mengele into auschwitz i believe
all these things now and i believe them
because of the trial by fire that i had
when i did the transfer agreement
professor sherwin offers a second and
very penetrating question if the
revisionist zionists led by vladimir
jabotinski and menachem began had been
controlling the jewish agency instead of
ham soros
would there have been a transfer
agreement would there have been german
reparations to the state of israel in
the 1950s and what what might have been
the economic and political outcomes for
the state of israel in its very early
history
well i'm often asked i'm constantly
asked what if questions on the transfer
agreement what if the boycott had
succeeded what if the trans agreement
had never been there but here's one i
think i can answer and it's very
dangerous if the is the sketchiest word
in history what if
i believe if the revisionist had
controlled the uh transfer agreement the
uh jewish agency at the time uh i doubt
very strongly that there would have been
a trans agreement with the nazis now
it's important for me to explain here
the uh the delicate fabrics of the
revisionist movement they had actually
good relations with the fascist italian
regime because they believed in a a very
strict organization they believed in in
that but i do not believe based upon
the uh immense
uh vituperative reaction of the
revisionist that they would have ever
allowed
uh the zionist organization and movement
to cut a deal with the nazis they would
have rather fought them and they did
fight them
and by the way
from that you can extrapolate
on your own
what the economic consequences would be
now would there have been reparations
to israel
those reparations were actually
calculated in 1938
by nachm goldman i had access to his
unprocessed papers at the american
jewish archives in 1938 and
1938 before the war broke out
years before auschwitz
was established the zionists were
already
anticipating the worst why because they
were realist because when hitler said
we're going to destroy the jews they
actually paid attention and they
actually went out and did mathematical
calculations
on
knocking goldman i have the report
i've never mentioned until this moment
on what the anticipated destruction
economic and human would be if hitler
succeeded and hitler almost
succeeded he succeeded 99 percent in
many countries
and
he was stopped but just barely
you mentioned 1938
that was also the year of chris falnock
we're coming up on the 71st anniversary
in another week or so and you wrote a
distinguished book on kristallnacht
right and one of the things i found in
my book 48 hours on kristallnacht uh was
that even after seeing what went on the
u.s government wasn't willing to
actively rescue jews
what did you find in your book and your
research about the u.s government's
position back in
33 in the time of this agreement well i
think that the doors began closing for
the jews very quickly
uh after uh the first months of 1933.
um uh there were refugees everywhere
we're talking about south africa we're
talking about um we're talking about
australia we're talk it was very common
for jews in germany to escape to austria
and in 1938 they went from austria to
czechoslovakia and then the germans
followed them there and from
czechoslovakia they went to france and
then the the germans took over france
and in a bifurcated fashion and um so it
it was
uh the jews when high invites men said
the world is divided into places where
jews are not allowed to be
and not allowed to go
it was the reality
and this was the uh
this was the dire challenge of the
zionists
there's an important dichotomy here
are we going to make an effort
to
to
restore
jewish civil rights
or to rescue jews for national rights
either take a dollar to keep a jew where
he is
and help him get through the starvation
imposed upon him we're going to take a
dollar and transfer him this is real
politic remember even the
relief packages
that were given to uh german jews to uh
get through starvation those also went
into the german economy those
it this is too complex to be black and
white and too complex for um it was
almost too complex for me that's why it
took about five years to figure out
wally ferris in washington dc was an
expert on middle east affairs and the
author of the confrontation winning the
war against future jihad
asks what do you what do you think would
have been the impact or lack of it on
the israeli economy in modern israel if
there had never been a transfer
agreement there are many institutions
today
such as mecca wrote the water company
which are taken for granted these are
infrastructural companies and these
companies occurred due to the investment
that came over came over the transfer of
assets now it's common for some people
to say the trans agreement did not
rescue people and rescued money that's
not true
it rescued people
it's true that the rescue of the
individuals was metered out in cadence
with the purchase and distribution of
nazi goods but the fact of the matter is
they had to buy these goods in order to
rest to rescue the the uh the pdp the
people now what's interesting is
when the jews were in concentration
camps
they didn't say i'm german
they didn't say i'm polish they said i'm
a zionist i wish to live
and the zionists endorsed that jews have
a right to live and they save the
remnant and they save the remnant with
the gun to the head and that gun
has never been removed
from the temple even though it's gone an
inch or two away the gun is still always
cocked and if i could just put a an
asterisk in for modern times we still
have today
the iranians trying to do in 12 minutes
what hitler could not do in 12 years
which is wipe out the jews and so the
zionists understood that there needs to
be a strong jewish state so that jews
have the same national aspirations other
groups do
martin cohen a student in jerusalem asks
why did so many other historians fail to
write about the transfer agreement than
the anti-nazi boycott
they didn't want to
the transfer agreement was understood
there were several treatises in german
and in hebrew academic circles it's not
like today where somebody does a
master's thesis and puts it up on the
internet and suddenly a million people
have have access to it when i went to
the leo beck institute in in new york
and i looked at the user guide the
finders aid and i said where are the uh
i i said the files are supposed to be in
this folder where are they they're not
in this file they're not in this cabinet
where are they he said they're
underneath my desk
and he gave them to me
the book tried to do what many
historians does not seek to do
which is to be um uh
all-encompassing on a narrow topic
instead of doing a a very slender matter
and so i had to work not in one or two
archives but in
20 or 30 and i had to put all this
together and this was how i be this was
the invention of the edwin black
approach to uh to holocaust
documentation never to look at one place
but 20 places and to put it all together
in a giant puzzle but the short answer
is why they didn't want to why why they
didn't do it they didn't want to
james matthew and by the way yes i
didn't want to
i could see why uh given uh
the uncomfort of the whole subject
james matthews in sydney is a reader who
wrote could the worldwide anti-nazi
boycott have toppled the hitler regime
if not undermined by the zionists or if
it was endorsed by the zionists
it's another one of these what if
questions
that is impossible to answer and
inappropriate to
answer but i'll try
the boycott
would not have been
kate was not capable of toppling the
german regime
because remember we're talking about a
regime people who quote statistics on
the german economy don't know what
they're talking about
this was an illegal corrupt economy that
stole other people's money as their own
economic wherewithal when they stopped
stealing it from their citizens they
stole it from neighboring countries the
fascist economy
so
it would only make the hitler regime
more desperate but what the boycott
could have done
is possibly in its early stage uh had an
impact on some of the policies and we
see it did have an impact because
without the boycott there would be no
transfer agreement the only reason the
nazis felt compelled
to negotiate with their enemies the
jewish nationalists was because this
boycott was a weapon that the nazis in
their mythical confusion actually feared
on the subject of the boycott joyce
nelson in new york another reader asked
was the anti-nazi boycott just a boycott
of jews or was it bigger than that it
was way bigger than that
uh it was never called a jewish boy it
was never called a jewish boycott
uh it there were catholics involved as
some of the greatest figures in the uh
uh new york are our archdiocese and
boston archdiocese were involved the
polish were involved labor unions were
involved the protestant community was in
involved uh the the organizers of the
boycott against the nazis were very
careful to sculpt this as not just a uh
um a a a a jewish tragedy but one which
was threatening the world you know what
they say the jews first and everybody
else second
and that's why they did it the way they
did it was extremely credit credible but
then when the jewish organizations
backed off the boycott because of the
transfer agreement it was left to a
bunch of unsupported
random people who for years
walked up and down the streets with
protest signs and still carried the
torch and i'm glad that they did both
were necessary we needed to protest the
hitler regime and we needed to save the
jews
i am not rely i am not unhappy that both
occurred
well kenneth babu fresno california
computer program wrestling asking
a related question
granted what you're saying about the
importance of the boycott he wonders did
the zionists cooperate too soon and for
too little
people need to understand the min uh
germany
if there was a zionist
who pushed too hard on his german
negotiator
he could be killed
he could be sent to a concentration camp
there was a limit to how far the
zionists could play their own cards and
the best card that they had
the best card was that people over there
who we can't control these american
jewish organizations are protesting by
the hundreds of thousands and
and bankrupting your your companies
which were falling by the waste by by by
by the wayside and we have the ability
to circumvent
to circumvent that so from the nazis
point of view they were dividing the
jewish community
with the trans agreement as well as
serving all these other interests that
i've discovered no they didn't
do too little too soon
they did as much as they could as soon
as they could but they did it in a
different set of modalities
a student in berlin dennis katz asks
did the zionists think that jewish
palestine would be safe from the nazis
or were they afraid that given hitler's
designs on the middle east that as well
that uh that would also be a dangerous
place i think it was always understood
by many that uh uh that hitler thought
of palestine as a great big prison camp
for the um a great big prison camp for
the jews they'd be put there in
palestine and then they could take over
over over the middle east
but uh i think designers thought uh
let's save the jews on monday and we'll
figure out what happens on friday you
know it's always been a jewish
aspiration we don't want to be killed
before shabbos
well let's finish with a last question
from joseph uh joseph meyers a retired
teacher here uh
in montreal
how did you work on the transfer or how
did your work on the transfer agreement
affect you personally and why is this
one event in washington your only event
on this book when you speak so often on
your other books
well
it's an appropriate final question
um
it affected me personally
in that it set me off
on a uh
circumnavigation
of the world of evil
and
as circumnavigating the world of evil
and injustice against the jews and other
groups
the further i go the more i end up at
the same point
and i always end up where i started
so it's done that to me
as to why this is uh my uh only event
um
because i choose to
i want to thank rabbi weinblatt for
stimulating discussion and edwin for a
very important book which even 25 years
later as you uh say uh still
covers and
uh offers a very powerful message for us
thank you and thank you thank you
thanks thank you mitch
edwin black is the author of many books
including ibm and the holocaust war
against the weak and internal combustion
he's the editor of the cutting edge news
for more information visit transfer
agreement dot com
sunday tufts university history
professor pinil joseph on the 1964